leadership is perhaps one of the most
misunderstood subjects in business
leadership has nothing to do with rank
I know many people who sit at the
highest levels of an organization
who are not leaders
we do as they tell us because they have
authority over us
but we do not trust them and we do not
follow them
I also know people at low levels of
organizations that have no formal
Authority
but they've made a choice the choice to
look after the person to the left of
them the choice to look after the person
to the right of them and we would trust
them and follow them anywhere
leadership is the awesome responsibility
to see those around us rise
you every one of us can choose to be the
leader we wish we had
we lead our teams and we can lead our
clients when we decide that we will do
everything in our power to see them rise
to see them achieve their Ambitions and
their dreams and this is what servant
leadership means I serve your dream
rather than you serve my bottom line
and it's totally fine to have financial
goals it's totally fine to have metrics
because that becomes the proof of value
that somebody wants to give you their
money because they believe in you it is
it is proof positive
but uh uh the best leaders I know
are students of leadership there's no
such thing as an expert leader it
doesn't exist like there's no such thing
as an expert parent it doesn't exist
right we are students of leadership and
even the most
senior leaders
constantly are reading books
reading articles watching talks having
conversations all the time about
leadership they're always in learning
mode
and I think for anyone who wants to be a
leader uh you have to choose to be a
student of the subject like anything if
you want to be good at something you
have to study it and the most
ignored characteristic of leadership you
know we talk about vision and Charisma
yes these are important but I've known
some wonderful leaders who don't have
huge world-changing vision
I've known some wonderful leaders that
are quiet and sit in the corner but they
all have courage
the courage to advance a vision the
courage to ignore the short-term ups and
downs of the business the courage to
take risks on people the courage to
believe in people
the courage to speak truth to power the
courage to do the right thing and have
integrity I think courage is a very
undervalued characteristic of leadership